Hey youtubers it's Charlie. Yesterday I asked
you all to submit your Arrow and Flash questions
so I picked 10 of them to answer in this video
with one bonus question. There were a ton
of Hong Kong Amanda Waller questions. Since
Stephen Amell has started talking about Season
3 we've gotten some good teasers for what's
going to be happening.
Real quick, if you're finding me for the first
time I do Marvel and DC videos every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. I'm
also working on a Special Star Wars video
for late tonight and I'm seeing Maleficent,
so that review will go up tomorrow.
Now let's talk about the unholy union of Oliver
and Amanda Waller and Flash whatnot.
Question 1 - Jedi Knight asks Do you think
we will ever get to see Slade's son in present
day?﻿
You're talking about Jericho, I think eventually
yes. Jericho appearing is completely dependent
on Slade's role on the show. If they use him
as part of a larger story then I think it
would be a good opportunity to bring him on.
Even if they decide to not feature Slade they
could always bring on a new character using
a false name and just develop him as a new
Roy type person.
Cut to the end of the season and it's revealed
he's really Slade's son and has no idea what
his father did in season 2 or that Oliver
was responsible for putting him in ARGUS jail.
They mentioned him a couple times between
Season 1 and Season 2, so they have to show
him eventually. Or at least tell us what happened
to him after Slade was marooned on the island.
I'd really like to know if he ever tried to
contact him after he escaped. He was pretty
juiced up though. So I wouldn't be surprised
if he did not.
Question 2 - Jaimer asks Where will Slade's
powers and enhanced brain function go? and
will they use the metahuman plot on The Flash
show to give Laurel real Black Canary powers?
When the mirakuru in his blood was neutralized
all of the benefits went away too. The mirakuru
was mostly a regenerative drug that also gave
people super strength. It didn't make Slade
super smart like he is in the comics. They
changed all that. He's still really clever,
but the only mental side effects of the drug
were negative ones, making him hallucinate
Shado.
And no I don't think Laurel is going to become
a metahuman. Even if she did, they would do
it on Arrow, not the Flash. The crossover
material that they do for Arrow and Flash
will be more driven by trying to defeat a
villain.
It's unclear how Oliver is going to get involved
in the Reactor Explosion Dark Energy plot
that they teased in the Flash Trailer. I would
guess that if you were not in the blast radius,
you're not getting super powers from that.
So all the new metahumans will just be people
in Central City when that happened.
Question 3 - cocotiks (no avatar) asks Since
Oliver is in Hong Kong will we get new characters
in the flashbacks?
Totally, I'm expecting too see new and familiar
faces. As for who some of those characters
might be, I think it will mostly be international
superheroes and villains. Otherwise why make
it all happen in Hong Kong, it's such a port
of call on that side of the world. Naturally
a lot of the criminal elements of the DC Universe
would pass through there at some point.
Amanda Waller as teased in season 1 was mostly
there to destabilize the Chinese government.
Presumably, the Hong Kong flashbacks will
spell out why and what else she was up to.
Question 4 - Malicious asks Do you think Komodo
or Onomatopoeia is going to be a major or
minor villain in Arrow season 3?﻿
I think Komodo is more likely, but they gave
a lot of his character traits and history
to Slade in Season 2. Like in the comics,
Komodo creates a plan to make Oliver lose
all his money and Oliver shoots one of his
eyes out with an Arrow. So they've already
combined the character with Deathstroke.
But it's totally possible that they could
use the character and just change the backstory
to focus more on his history with Shado.
If you're not familiar with Komodo, his real
name is Simon Lacroix and he grew up working
for Queen Industries, learned archery from
Oliver's father Robert Queen and turned evil.
Question 5 - Jhon Harper asks do you think
that John Diggle will become a green lantern?
If not do you think that green lantern will
be in arrow or flash?﻿
I don't think they'd do something as big as
that without a multi season arc. And just
because Hal Jordan is the most iconic Green
Lantern, I think the Flash TV Show would get
first crack at teasing the character, just
because Jordan is also a Central City character.
They've teased Ferris Airlines before, so
I think we'll see more Green Lantern teasers.
If they do anything Diggle related with Green
Lantern, it will just be having him make some
jokes about Green costumes, rings or have
him rhyme something like the Green Lantern
motto.
In terms of actually seeing a Green Lantern
character on either show, I think definitely
eventually. The Green Lantern movie flopped,
so Warner Bros probably won't have a problem
demoting the character to TV status. But it
took 2 years to get to Barry Allen, so don't
expect another spinoff character like that
till Arrow Season 4 or The Flash Season 2.
Question 6 - Jack Gutman (no avatar) asks
Hey Charlie how 'bout a shoutout, my Birthday
is on Saturday?
Everybody be sure to give Jack a Birthday
high five!
Question 7 - Daedelus (no avatar) asks what
other non natural abilities or powers will
appear on Arrow?﻿
It looks like they've been able to do a pretty
good job with weather and energy based special
effects, just looking at the Flash Trailer.
But because Oliver isn't a superhuman. They're
probably going to steer away from comic book
characters with crazy powers. It makes more
sense to put Oliver next to other characters
of similar ability.
There's always exceptions. The only one right
now is named Barry Allen. And he'll only be
next to Oliver on screen a couple of times
this year.
The Flash is a whole different story. Because
he's got crazy powers via Speedforce those
limitations you have with Oliver are out the
window. Just because I'm a sucker for the
classics, I'd say the first other super powers
we'll see will be Rogue based powers. Like
Captain Cold freezing stuff.
Question 8 - Adrian (no avatar) asks do you
think we'll see the league of assassins in
the hong kong flashbacks?
That would be so awesome. I definitely think
we'll see references to them. But I don't
think they'll be the primary antagonist, like
Ed Fyers was on the island. Oliver did say
that he heard 'things' about Ra's Al Ghul,
so he had to hear them from somewhere. It's
stands to reason that place could have been
Hong Kong.
Question 9 - Niloy (no avatar) asks is there
going to be any reference flashpoint storyline
on the flash tv series?
So they're starting the show off using a modified
version of the Flash Rebirth story and the
new 52 Origin story. Geoff Johns is on the
writing staff and he wrote Flash for a long
time, so expect lots of references to golden
age, silver age and recent Flash stuff. Flashpoint
included.
But since Flashpoint was such a universe altering
event, I think they'll just make references
to it. The Particle Accelerator Explosion
is kind of the macguffin for season 1, the
dark energy it releases creating all the new
metahumans is going to be where they mine
most of the story from week to week.
Question 10 - Alex Garcia asks, do you think
we'll see Felicity Flashbacks from before
she met Oliver
Originally when Stephen Amell talked about
learning more about Felicity in Season 2 he
made it sound like we were supposed to get
way more info and it just got edited out at
the last minute. I don't expect a lot of Flashbacks
like we get with Hong Kong and the Island,
but I do think Felicity will start talking
about her past before she met everyone. Or
talk about it more.
Usually it takes something traumatic for that
to happen. So I think something will happen
with her family that will make her want to
talk to Oliver about it. And that's when we
learn more. I don't think she's going to get
any solo episodes where she goes off on her
own without Team Arrow for an entire hour.
Bonus Question - LordLaxton (no avatar) asks,
do you think they'll introduce a new supervillain
in season 3 like they in season 2 when they
did Barry Allen?
So you're asking about them bringing a major
character into the Arrowverse, like someone
big enough to get a spinoff. I think they'll
definitely bring someone in who can stand
by themselves. They'd have to, just to top
Deathstroke. I think whoever it ends up being
will be a lateral move, like they're not going
to get a supervillain with real super powers.
It will be someone like Deathstroke or Merlyn
who Oliver actually has a chance of defeating,
with a little help from Felicity of course.
I'm sure Stephen Amell will be talking more
about the new villain at Comic Con this summer.
So that's probably when we'll get more teasers.
So thanks so much for submitting questions
everyone! These are always a ton of fun to
do. I'll be posting my next Arrow and Flash
videos next Wednesday, so be sure to subscribe
to get everything. And feel free to leave
me suggestions for bonus topics.
Tonight I'm seeing Maleficent, so I'll probably
post my review Friday. Don't worry, there
will be spoiler warnings. I've also got a
special Star Wars Episode 7 Spinoff movie
video I'm working on. That will be my next
video.
You can click here to get it. I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it. And you can
click here to learn more about Arrow Season
3 and the Flash Season 1.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!